- We'll use the back of this couch, here.
This is you.
Can you? Are we filming that?
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- Maybe, I don't even know if this is
going to be worthwhile,
but we'll say this.
The best way to get involved,
to get started in anything
is to be willing to work for free.
Internships to me are
the path to anything.
A lot of people come just to
hear what they already want
to hear like codify this into five
principles I can then apply to my life.
I know so many people who
think they want to appeal
to everyone by being generic and universal
and you appeal to nobody.
- He's an American author,
journalist, and ghostwriter.
He's best known for his
best-selling book, "The Game:
"Penetrating the Secret
Society of Pick-Up Artists."
He's a contributing
editor for Rollingstone
and also writes regularly
for the New York Times.
He's Neil Strauss, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules of Success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also as Neil is talking,
if he says something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(swoosh)
(upbeat music)
- Here's my advice, just choose anything.
It doesn't even matter
just choose anything.
So here's an example if
you're, so I wish I could
almost draw it, but I'll
tell you what, like.
Let's see what can I use as a.
We'll use the back of this couch here.
This is you.
Can you, are we filming that?
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- I don't even know if this
is going to be worthwhile,
but we'll say this.
- [Interviewer] Try it.
- [Neil] This is you,
right, and you're like,
"I don't know what to do.
"I'm not sure what to do."
And you're just sort of sitting
here doing nothing, right?
This little white stain.
I don't even know what it is.
It's Lamar Burton's back sweat.
Is that his name?
Lamar? LeVar Burton.
I don't know, it could be
anyone's sweat right there.
So that's you, that little piece of sweat,
toiling and trying to decide what to do,
but then just choose freaking anything.
Let's just say, "Oh, I
want to be an actor."
Just, who cares?
Maybe you don't. I don't know.
Just choose one thing.
So you choose one thing,
and now you have a goal.
Right, just choose a goal.
It doesn't matter now.
Maybe you're going to
start going to auditions.
You're going to auditions, and then wait,
you got a job, but it's a voiceover work.
It's a, or maybe it's on radio.
You get a little radio gig, so now
you're like, "Oh, radio's fun.
"I'm going to be a radio host."
and that's your next goal.
And then you get a call to do
like voiceover on a cartoon
or something here, and you're like,
"Okay, I'll be a cartoon voice,"
and guess what, now
you're actually moving,
and maybe you will end up being a
you know the voice of whatever, you know,
the next Pixar movie
or something like that.
- [Interviewer] Eugene Mirman.
He's a voice in Bob's Burgers.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, along with.
There's somebody good.
John H.
John Benjamin, is that his name?
- [Interview] Oh.
- He was also in Home Movies.
He was great, anyway.
The point is like just
just choose one thing to move toward,
and then the path, and
then just go with the path,
and you'll end up somewhere.
If you're standing here
trying to decide what to do,
you'll still be here in a year,
two years, three years, four years.
Just choose something you
kind of like and don't hate,
and then start moving toward it,
and you'll find that the
course and path of life
will bring you exactly
where you're supposed to be.
- So you've sort of arrived
at these different approaches
to writing, what was
the first to your mind,
like the first writing piece that you did
that kind of put you on the map.
Where, not like, I've
arrived, but you're like,
"Okay, I actually, I
actually could make this work
"or I could actually
really be good at this."
Or wow, I just got
recognition for this piece.
I mean, was, were there
any sort of defining
moments in your career as a writer?
- Yeah, I think, I mean I don't know.
I'm not, yeah, I mean the
things that I remember
like I was like
by the way, the best way to
get involved is get started
in anything is to be
willing to work for free.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Internships like to me
are the path to anything and
I mean I could really think being.
There's definitely a lot
of people who are entitled,
basically,
I have some words to say, but anyway.
If you want to live in your passion,
whatever your passion is,
you have to be willing
to not make money at it.
If you want to do what you love,
you've got to do, you have
to, you have a choice.
You can choose money or you
can choose what you love that.
Joseph Campbell has a great
quote that I always use.
I don't know if you guys know this, the.
- Joseph Campbell, so "The
Hero with the Thousand Faces."
- Yeah, the great kind of
professor of mythology,
but he said, "The insecure."
Have you guys heard this?
"The insecure was is the secure way."
You guys have heard that quote?
And what it means basically is, you know,
my parents, and I'm sure like
most people's parents say,
"Get a good job, try and make some money,
"make a good living," and
because they think that's secure.
If you make, go and make
money, but if you do a job
and you make money and lose that job,
then you lose the money, you have nothing.
- Right, right, right.
- What he says is you choose your passion.
It actually doesn't matter
whether you make money
or you lose money because
you're always going
to have your passion and be happy,
so it doesn't actually matter.
- And that's your safety net.
- Right.
And but the challenge of that
is it might be eight years
or four years before you're
actually making a living at it.
- Yep.
- Versus, versus something else.
There's four things when
someone gives you feedback
or criticism however it's
intended, whether ill or positive,
and so one is not to take it
in, but to kind of catch it.
I think of like a catcher's mitt.
If you tell me something,
you come across this way,
I'll grab it, and I'll look at it,
and I'll think, okay, is it true?
If it's true, cool, I'll
put it in and learn from it.
If I think it's not true, cool,
I'll throw it away, no harm, no foul.
I'm not going to dwell on it, right?
And I think everybody
needs this in this world
because we're all on, most
of us are on social media,
and we're all getting like,
you know, all our thoughts
are getting picked apart,
you know, all the time,
so we really need this more than ever.
Then the third one is, you get it
and it's a maybe or I'm not sure.
You said this about me, I'm not sure.
You know, what do you guys think?
You know what do you think?
I'll ask my friends, and
I'll ask other people
and get some feedback, and if it's true,
cool, maybe I'll learn from it.
If everyone's like this is total nonsense,
ignore that dude, I throw it out.
But then there's a fourth one,
and this is where the real growth is.
Do you know what the fourth one is?
- I don't.
- The fourth one is, you
get it, you throw it out.
I'm talking to you, and then maybe
later I'm talking to, you know, you.
I get it, and I'm like nah, it's not true,
and then later I'm
talking to someone else.
I get it, it's the third time it's
come back to me, I throw it out.
I'm like, wait, maybe I
got to take this thing
a little more seriously,
and it becomes a maybe,
and then it becomes a yes,
and that's when the big growth
thing is because you kept
ignoring this thing that was
in your face, so the best
feedback, like where you really
grow is you keep getting
the same feedback,
you keep dismissing it,
at some point you say,
"wait, maybe they have something."
So one way I do this is
I get together a group of
people, and we sit together
once a week, and talk about
the (bleep) stuff going on in our lives.
I find group therapy really powerful
because if it's just one on one,
I can say I just disagree with you,
but when four or five people are saying,
"Hey dude, no you're really
coming off like that,"
or you're really having this
problem in your relationship
and maybe need to look at it,
and five people are saying it
like it's pretty hard to dismiss them.
I know a lot of my friends
have written really, really
successful books, and even I
wrote a book called "The Game,"
which has probably sold like
millions of copies, and
really when I wrote it,
I thought nobody would read it.
I thought nobody would
read it, but I thought,
this story's so crazy I just
have to tell this story.
So these things that seem
you can spend all your time
trying to engineer the perfect thing,
and the truth is, we have no control.
We just don't know what's going
to work or what's not going to work.
For example, a lot of marketers
say to follow your audience,
see what your audience wants,
and the problem with following
your audience, for those of
you who even have audiences
already, I've seen it, it
can become a trap because all
your audience knows is what
you've done in the past.
They don't know what you're
going to do in the future,
so if you're following your audience,
you're already trapped.
You know, your audience
should be following you
as you move forward through
life, and it gets harder.
And again, because I talk
to so many musicians,
you think, okay, is it true
that as musicians or artists
get older they just don't get as good
'cause they're not young
and in touch any more.
It's not really true.
What happens is they get
trapped in their own success.
They get trapped in what
their audience wants of them,
and they get trapped in
having responsibilities.
So sort of being in touch with you
and going where you want
to go and not being afraid
to leave people behind is what's going
to actually make you a leader.
Here's the secret to life.
Don't take it personally.
Not just for pickup but
for life in general.
Everyone's a jerk to you someday,
and when someone's an
asshole in the street
and bumps in to you and says, "duff,"
it's not about you, it's
you know, he's a jerk.
If you have a day and you
lose your job and your
girlfriend breaks up with you
and you crash your car,
the world doesn't hate you,
you just had a bad day.
So same thing, it'll
make life so much easier
if you don't take it personally,
which means that as you go in this world
your friends are not going
to tell you the truth
about the things that are
really wrong with yourself,
so as you enter this world
and you talk to guys,
you're going to find out what
your problems are and what they aren't.
When they tell it to you,
don't take it personally.
You think about it, and you
got to have this filter inside.
I think this is what allowed me to excel.
You have to have this
filter inside that takes in
all criticism, not personally
and not judgmentally,
you take in the criticism
you think, "Is that true?"
You take a hard look at
yourself, and if it's true,
you work to solve it and change it.
If it's not true, you just
throw it out and move out
because as you go there, we're
here because we're admitting
we need something better in our lives.
We're here because we're admitting
we're a little bit broken.
There's something we
need to learn we haven't.
So as you do it,
you want to take in all
the criticism that comes in
and work on what you need to work on,
so don't take it personally.
- How do you think of yourself?
How do you describe yourself?
And I think about this
because words matter,
and I know that we're all
becoming a bunch of hyphens,
like I consider myself a photographer,
director, entrepreneur.
I'm getting tired of it.
How do you describe yourself?
- I mean if I had to say like one thing
maybe it would be a storyteller.
I just like to tell
really great, compelling
stories that if it's a
book, you can't put it down.
If it's a movie or a TV
show, you can't turn it off.
So to me, it's the art of storytelling,
which I think is probably
one of the oldest
human art forms there is.
- Yeah, like caveman
times, they're like sitting
around the fire, even like that's what
cave paintings are, right?
They're scratching out a story.
- I always encourage people.
This is probably true for
people listening right now
that people love to read nonfiction.
They want to get a book that's
going to tell them what to do
and a bulleted list of what
the should or are supposed
to do, but I really believe that the
mind learns through metaphor.
Right, that storytelling is to learn
how you learn the roles of your tribe
or your culture or the world or
about being a human being,
you learn through metaphor,
and I really think we
undervalue storytelling
this like quick fix culture.
- Oh
- When Tim said that I'm,
you know, I'm very methodical
about time management
because it's so hard to do.
So the first things, I'll
give you a couple of important
life changing tips for anyone trying
to do something creative on the computer.
So number one thing is
no e-mail in the morning.
Like number one thing is
there's a program called Freedom
that I downloaded, and it says.
And I love the word freedom
because actually what it is, it says,
"How many minutes of freedom do you want?"
You say whatever it is, 90 minutes,
and then you cannot access
the internet for 90 minutes.
There's no unlock code.
People are gasping.
You're all going to use it, yeah.
There's no unlock 'cause
the first thing I do is
phone, I give to someone else
or put it in a drawer somewhere.
It's best if I give it to someone else.
Internet goes off, and
I commit to that amount,
a certain amount of time, so
my thing is that it's compartmentalizing.
That if you're going to check your e-mail,
check it from four to five.
They have a, there's a,
someone wrote a book,
which I never read that's called,
"Never Check Your E-mail in the Morning."
You don't, I don't know if
you're going to read it or not,
but just know the title,
and that's really great.
It's great, but the thing is with time,
it's to become proactive about time
instead of reactive because
I know so many people
who can't do anything because
you're getting a message
on Facebook, and then you're getting a,
an e-mail, and then you're
just reacting to that
because it feels like you're
getting something done.
At the end of the day,
you got nothing done,
so I, what my thing is I'm really,
and everyone knows that
I'm proactive about that
to the degree that,
and by the way I'd have Facebook
and Twitter blocked on my computer.
What I did is I downloaded Intego Content,
I think it's a content
barrier, whatever it is.
- [Interviewer] The rest
of time can be used.
- Net Nanny.
- Net Nanny can be used
to block specific sites.
And I had someone else put in
a password for those sites,
so I don't even know the passwords,
so I couldn't get into Twitter
or Facebook if I tried.
So finding those things that are those
and putting walls between you and them
or limiting them in certain ways.
There's one other thing
I was going to say was.
Oh, which is, friends
can be a pain in the ass
if you're trying to be creative,
and if you have more than seven friends,
and everyone wants to
see you one day a week,
what do you do?
So another thing I want to say is
I do a Wednesday night dinner party,
so if my friends want to see me, I'm like,
"Great, Wednesday."
If someone wants a meeting
who I'm not sure about,
Wednesday night, so
Wednesday night, we all go to
a restaurant and basically,
whoever I want to see
or catch up on, I'll see them there,
and then maybe afterward I'll break off
with my closer friends, but that way,
I can see everyone, people
who I want to meet with,
but I don't really want to take the time
for a lunch or meeting one-on-one.
If I like them I talk to them a bunch.
If I don't, I put them far away.
Humility is the most important thing
that you can have to work for change.
If you really want to have a big change.
A lot of people will come
just to hear what they
already want to hear like codify this
into five principles I
can then apply to my life.
You know you get your codify is the word,
and I'll codify, I'll codify
some self-awareness for you.
But humility to recognize
you know, what got you
here won't get you there
as the saying goes, right?
And to say at some point,
if you really want to change
and you're really stuck,
"I know nothing, I'm
letting go of everything,
"and I'm sort of going to relearn
"as with like a childlike mind."
We treat ourselves horribly,
we talk to ourselves in ways
that we would never, ever
allow a stranger to talk to us.
We take your self,
if someone in here walked
up to you and said,
"You're not interesting,"
"You've got nothing good to say,"
"You're not enough,"
"You're not attractive,"
you'd be like, "you
(bleep), mother (bleep)."
(laughter)
Right?
So, why do we allow ourselves
to talk to ourself that way?
Right, so there's sort of a
message that I will give you
guys today as I'm trying
to help you get over
approaching anxiety, is start
treating yourself the way
you want that person you're approaching
to be treating you, right?
If she says that she,
she's not going to say
anything half as mean as the
(shit) you're telling yourself.
So you have nothing to
fear anymore, right?
'Cause you all have given
yourself the worst of it.
If I could give you like one
thing this whole weekend,
it'd be to stop talking
to yourself this way.
So every version has this
course while I aim action.
You may feel like you're getting nothing
but rejection, right, but
where is that coming from?
Like you were saying earlier,
if you're giving someone
more worth and value,
higher status than yourself,
you're loving them more
what is that saying?
That's shame, shame about who you are,
shame that you're not worthy
to talk to this person.
Shame that this person somehow
still has some power over you
or is going to hurt you,
and that you're not enough.
That you're not good enough.
That you're not attractive enough.
That you're not
rich enough.
That you're not socially
comfortable enough
or too awkward, whatever it is.
That's shame about who you are.
And what happens, right, your shame
when you walk in turns to joy.
So the whole idea is, if
you're going to approach
from a place of joy instead
of a place of shame,
you will have no approaching anxiety.
And that's what we call,
what I call and they call
having an A game day is being in state.
You're being in state, which
is just really having joy.
So they walk in and you walk up,
and you're like, "Okay,
all right there are all
"these people, and they're
going to approve of me,
"and if they approve of me, I'm going
"to feel good about myself,
and if they don't approve
"of me, I'm going to feel
(bleep) about myself,
"and I'm going to go out
and put my self-esteem
"in the hands of every
stranger I talk to."
You're just setting
yourself up for trouble.
You know, you can push past it
using a lot of this
full mentality of love,
but you're starting off with
a giant, giant handicap.
Don't hold anything back.
When someone asked Heidi
earlier what had really worked
for her, she was like,
I think you said like,
"Sharing my feelings."
Is that what you said?
And I find that so many people
when they're going to write,
they just want to show
like a glorified side
of themselves that everyone can relate to.
There's a quote from Carl Rogers,
the psychologist, who says,
"The personal is the universal."
I know so many people who
think they're going to appeal
to everyone by being
generic and universal,
and you appeal to nobody,
but if you talk from
your heart, and you say
the most personal stuff,
the stuff you're scared.
By the way, the only
book, reason my books,
I think are successful is
'cause I say the (bleep)
that I'm too scared to tell
my friends or tell people.
Somehow I can write it,
and when you write it,
people read it, "Oh
yeah, I relate to that.
"No one's said that before,
but that's exactly what I'm,
"what I'm going through."
So don't hold back.
There's a difference between
just vomiting emotion all over the page.
It still has to be,
follow the number one rule
of being interesting, right,
but the stuff you're too scared
to tell everyone, that's the stuff
you should be writing about and sharing.
And that thought that you think maybe
is going to get you unliked,
and it's a scary time
right now in the culture because
everything, we get instant
feedback on everything,
right, everything we write,
we get instant feedback.
We know everybody's opinion, which
if you don't have a rock
solid sense of who you are
and what you're doing
can lead to just trying
to conform and be liked,
and I promise you.
I wrote a book called "Everyone
Loves You When You're Dead,"
and the reason, it was
interviews with celebrities
because when you're dead,
you're no longer competition.
As long as you're here, right?
If no one doesn't like what you're doing,
then you're probably not
doing anything interesting.
Right?
If everyone, if you're only
getting positive feedback,
then you're probably not doing
anything new or interesting, right?
So let some negativity be a sign
that "Okay, good, I'm actually saying
"something new and something meaningful."
(swoosh)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
James Esler asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it
in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Neil say
that had the biggest impact on you.
What lesson did you take from this video
that you're going to immediately
apply to your life or business?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, want to give a quick
shoutout to Phanta Media.
Thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word" and posting
that great picture to Instagram.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- Number one rule in writing is this.
Nobody cares.
Nobody cares about you.
They don't care about your thoughts.
They don't care about your ideas.
They don't care about
what you have to say,
what you did yesterday, or anything.
They do not give a (bleep).
And from there can you make them care?
Everything I write, I
assume that nobody cares,
that they have no interest, and if I start
from that perspective,
and if I can draw you in
through the writing, that's
where the story begins.
So just assume, start by
assuming nobody cares,
and how can you draw them in
to your story or your point.
Number two then, one way to draw them in
is something called the open loops.
Who here knows what an open loop is?
Cool, has anyone seen the
new Doctor Strange movie?
Anyone seen that?
Cool, Kyle you saw it, so is it good?
Okay by the way, that's an open loop.
An open loop was I asked
you what an open loop was
and then rather than explaining it,
I went on to another subject and talked
about Doctor Strange or something.
So an open loop is, I
can start with something
that captures your
attention and 98 percent
of you didn't know what an open loop is.
You're probably curious about it by now
because I've been talking for two minutes
and still haven't explained it yet, right?
An open loop is that at the
top I tell you something
that you're interested in and you want
to know the answer to
and wait 'til the end.
How many times have we just
stayed through a really
(bleep) movie just 'cause you want to know
what happens at the end, right?
It can be the worst movie ever,
but I want to know how
that happened, right?
So an open, so one is to
use the idea of open loops,
and it's true in relationships.
You meet somebody you
have a lot in common with,
and you start telling all these stories.
You want it to continue.
So an open loop is a great
way to create intrigue
because we're creatures who
love storytelling, right?
Early, early, storytelling
is part of our sort of
our DNA, so creating open
loops at the top of a post or
in a book is really powerful.
So yeah the best, I'd say
the best advice for anyone
who wants to write a book is literally,
the best way to write a book is
to have a looming, impending deadline
with hard, real world
consequences for missing it.
- [Tim] Stakes, remember
stakes, guys? Honestly.
- Yeah, did you know I put out stakes?
- [Tim] Yeah, you need stakes.
- Like stakes to be--
- [Tim] I talked to--
- Day old diet or the S-T-A-K-E-S?
- Oh yes, stakes. This is, yeah not like.
Stakes like vampire stakes
but for consequences.
- And I think that.
- That's something that a media
coach said to me recently,
and they were like when you
say stakes, and you have a book
called "The Four Hour Chef,"
they're going to think
you're talking about steaks.
Like (groan).
- But I think if you can't
do it, you manufacturer it.
You talk about it at stake.com,
and things like that, but I
really know that literally,
you know Tim's always,
Tim would be calling,
and I would be calling Tim
saying, "I got to get this in.
"I got like three months.
"I can't do," but literally,
if we didn't have those
deadlines you wouldn't have
written three books in this
amount of time.
- [Interviewer] It would never
have happened. It would
never have happened.
- Yeah, so you have to,
so I'll do that if a friend
of mine wants to write a book,
and they want me to proofread
it or take a look at it,
I'll say, "I'll take a look
at it, but what date are you
"going to get it done by 'cause I'm going
to hold you to it," and
they'll say, "January."
I say, "If it's not done
by the end of March,
"I'm not going to read your
book at all no matter what."
So I'll give consequences
and deadlines to my friends,
so it's a good way to write is to really
if you don't have a publisher or a deal
or something like that, find some
real consequences that's
externally imposed.
You have to learn from your mistakes.
No, I have this attitude that
no situation is impossible.
There is nothing impossible.
There're just contingencies
and obstacles to get around,
so if I went out and
I'm just trying to think of obstacles.
Let's just say you did an opener,
and she'd heard it already.
You did your line, and
she'd heard it already
because your friend just approached
her with it 10 minutes ago.
Do you run screaming?
Maybe that happens the first time.
The second time you say,
"If that happens again, what do I do?"
You say, "Oh my god, you
must have met my friend.
"That's really funny."
"We were just talking about
that," and problem solved.
Whatever it may be, say you,
any problem has a solution,
so I kind of have that attitude.
You know, what if she's with eight guys?
What if
she is
on her way out the door?
Any problem is going to have a solution.
So you have to have that attitude, and
if something goes wrong,
and I'm saying this in a positive way,
not a negative self-esteem way,
but if something goes wrong,
it's always your fault.
That's what I feel like.
I'm not being hard on myself if something
goes wrong, it's never her fault.
She's not a bitch.
She is not mean.
She is not uptight.
I did something wrong to
make her uncomfortable.
So for example with the openers,
I would start walking up and saying,
"Hey guys, I want to get
an opinion on something.
"I got this question I'm trying to ask.
"Can I start asking it?"
But I noticed they
weren't really listening.
They were tuning me out.
They were kind of giving
me bad body language.
So I realized what are they thinking?
Why is that happening?
Well it's happening because
I'm standing around.
They don't know when I'm going to leave,
so I added what's called
a time constraint.
I'd walk in, I'd say, "Hey guys,
"I want to get a quick
opinion on something.
"By the way, I can only stay for a second
"'cause I got to rejoin
my friends over there."
You know, problem solved.
So any time something went
wrong or was I coming.
Maybe I would do everything,
and I felt like I was doing
it perfectly, but people
weren't interested.
Well I was doing it, doing
all the right things,
but I was doing it in a very needy way.
A lot of people will read the material,
and they'll say, "This doesn't work."
Everything works.
What I say is going to be
different than what Zan says
and different than what someone else says.
It all works.
You just have to do it right.
So for example, the opinion
openers we're talking about.
The opinion opener is how
you start a conversation.
If you go and you say, "Can I ask
"you a question on something?"
And they say, "No, we're talking.
"Get lost."
Well
the opinion openers don't work.
You just did it wrong.
You walk and you say,
"Hey guys, I want to ask
a quick question on something."
Now you haven't asked
them a yes no question,
and it's going to work, so
there's so many little subtleties.
Did that make sense?
Okay.
So there's so many.
I saw someone looking at me strangely.
So there's so many little subtleties
that you have to work in,
and it's always, always
going to be
your fault that it's not working.
Not in a negative way, and
not in being hard on yourself.
It's feedback so you can improve yourself.
That whole idea that there's
no such thing as failure.
There are only learning lessons.
So that's what I did,
but you know what, I'm a
guy who's hard on myself,
but I'm hard on myself because
it makes me excel usually.